day 18 tonight there is an ongoing mass
hostage situation in the i guess islamic
emirates of afghanistan 13 american
soldiers dead more than 20 injured more
than 100 innocent civilians also killed
many others injured but yesterday joe
biden he decided to take a victory lap
he congratulated himself on a job well
done joe biden's mission accomplished
moment take a look the extraordinary
success of this mission
was due to the incredible skill
bravely
and selfless courage of the united
states military and our diplomats
and intelligence professionals
now some say
we should have started mass evacuation
sooner
and couldn't this have been done have
been done in a more orderly manner
i respectfully disagree
and joe's chief of staff ron klain the
great puppeteer he took it a step
further announced that the withdrawal
could not have gone any smoother
yes it could have take a look
it's easy to second guess but let's just
be clear america was in this war for 20
years and i think any effort to unwind
that any effort to bring our troops out
any effort to end our military presence
in afghanistan was going to be filled
with
heartbreaking scenes and difficulties
and i think the biden administration has
managed that as well as it can be
managed under the circumstances we were
placed in
like biden ron clayne really that
delusional is he really this much of an
idiot it appears so nothing about
that withdrawal being managed well
nothing wrong not a single thing if
you're watching you might want to pass
on to your boss that i'm sure is in
dreamland about this time
this new ad from senate republicans and
it might help jog his ever failing
memory about what really happened in
afghanistan take a look
is a taliban takeover of afghanistan now
inevitable no
it is not
the likelihood there's going to be
a taliban overrunning everything and
owning the whole country is highly
unlikely
this is not just about the overall idea
of leaving afghanistan this is about
leaving hastily and ineptly secretary
blinken how did president biden get this
so wrong with an emboldened and stronger
taliban that has greater access to
weapons and technology that we supplied
despite the president's promise that the
withdrawal of american troops would be
responsible deliberate and safe the
biden administration is now trying to
explain why the u.s was so caught off
guard
breaking news and it's difficult can
confirm that a number of u.s service
members were killed at the kabul airport
do you bear any responsibility
for the way that things have unfolded in
the last two weeks i bear responsibility
for
fundamentally all that's happened
i think that ad is devastating take a
look at this new ad from president
trump's save america political action
committee watch this one
afghanistan cannot be used as a
terrorist base that afghanistan has
become in disneyland for
terrorists plan for every contingency
total chaos it is heartbreaking it is
depressing it's a failure and he needs
to own that failure very responsibility
for all that's happened he did not admit
any mistakes he did not
offer any change of course he says we're
going to continue forward he really
isn't taking responsibility mr biden you
did this you made the deal with the
taliban this is the consequences of it
tens of thousands of people being left
behind there's american citizens left
we're going to get them all out we did
not get everybody out dozens and dozens
of u.s citizens went to the airport and
the gates never opened
our mission hasn't failed
yet
if this isn't failure
what does failure look like exactly
but uh
there's you know there to be
that's what joe biden calls an
extraordinary success he says it was the
right decision the wise decision the
best decision
unparalleled results
wow and then he went on to say what a
magnificent display of public policy i
ask again
if that's success
how do we define failure because today
joe biden took again zero questions he
was exhausted from yesterday yelling at
us and lecturing of us and he apparently
wants to move past his afghan debacle
this crisis is not over and by the way
the war is not over either
americans are held hostage right now
behind enemy lines and even today the
washington post reported that a hundred
u s government sponsored journalists and
their families all left behind by joe
biden in afghanistan there are now
hundreds and hundreds maybe more than a
thousand americans with no way out and
of course we have no update on the exact
number or their whereabouts no concrete
plan at all to rescue them we have no
diplomats on the ground we have no
military on the ground no accurate
accounting
even of how many americans are behind
enemy lines this is unforgivable these
americans have been left behind and
abandoned by their president
i never thought i'd see this in my
lifetime you know i thought you didn't
leave people behind joe
you said it over and over and over again
we don't leave people behind you said it
two weeks ago joe you promised over and
over again
in case you forgot which is probably
highly likely take a look
if there's american citizens left we're
going to stay to get them all out this
town
this state this country
takes care of our own
leave nobody behind
giving everyone a fair shot leaving
nobody behind
that we do take care of our own that we
leave nobody behind to help everyone in
need
look out for one another leave nobody
behind but we will leave no one behind
it's what america is all about
it's about pulling together
leaving nobody behind
giving hate no safe harbor
and leaving no one behind re-weaving
that social fabric
that holds a society together honesty
decency hope
leaving nobody behind
joe
you left them behind they're behind
enemy lines what are you going to do
about it just leave them there also
breaking late last night a whistle
blower providing a transcript of a phone
call between joe biden and afghan
president ghani you know the guy that
fled with millions of dollars this phone
call from july from reuters quote in
much of the call biden focused on what
he called the afghan government's
perception problem
i need not tell you the perception
around the world and in parts of
afghanistan i believe is that things are
not going well in terms of the fight
against the taliban biden said and there
is a need whether it's true or not we
all knew it was true there is a need to
project a different picture
everybody knew it was true that great
well-trained afghan army that biden was
bragging about the same month was yeah
disintegrating right before the eyes of
the world not not lies joe perceptions
you cared about the lying part
perceptions don't matter lives matter
and anyway he asked gani to lie for him
and pretend all is well you got to tell
people everything's going great so then
joe biden could take his victory lap
after ending america's quote longest war
but as president trump once said the
truth is a force of nature so here we
are 13 dead american heroes and untold
hundreds and hundreds of our fellow
americans hostages behind enemy lines a
new report from john solomon
at just the news.com u.s soldiers
involved with the evacuation they could
not believe what was happening they
didn't want to leave a single american
behind quote we are bleeping abandoning
american citizens an army colonel
assigned to the 82nd airborne division
wrote sunday in frustration one former
special forces soldier working with
private networks because biden wasn't
going to do it and the military to
rescue stranded americans texted quote
you guys left american citizens at the
gate of kabul airport three empty jets
paid for by volunteers were waiting for
them you and i talked on the phone i
told you where they were gave you their
passport images and my email and my
phone number you left them behind
americans stranded at the gate as empty
planes took off
now nobody's there to help them biden
has no plan
whatsoever to get any of them out he
says he's got leverage no that would be
the taliban and probably isis k that of
all the leverage the leverage our fellow
citizens